some of the best hair looks that i'm
known for are probably the long
sleek glass hairstyle that was a great
trend
the um it was all about shiny glossy
hair and then probably a high snatch
ponytail i think like a high
snatched kind of red carpet worthy
ponytail they're probably some of the
main looks i'm looking for
some of the clients that i travel with
most often are probably
jlo um kim kardashian um
they're kind of probably the most that
i'm traveling with right now probably
when i went to tahiti with kim for her
birthday that was
really magical it was kind of one of
those one-off experiences where it's a
pinch me moment
um it was an island in the middle of the
sea it really was
one to remember my most used product is
the color wow dreamcoat i use it to prep
every head of hair
before any look because it gives me a
transformation
in the hair texture which is just
unbeatable
i probably go through i'd say about 100
bottles a year
[Music]
hey guys so today i'm going to show you
one of my favorite looks right now
it's the bombshell look beautiful glossy
silky hair
in a few simple steps the key look to
getting a bombshell wave
is about getting a great preparation for
the hair so i'm going to use the
colourwell dreamcoat
you can really layer it off and make
sure each bit of the hair and each
strand of the hair
get that amazing technology to transform
the texture so what we're going to do
now guys is we're actually going to take
the hair into a slightly off
center part so i like to do this quite
roughly just because i think the look
should have volume and it should be
quite glamorous and natural and then
we're going to use the leandro limited
hair dryer and a bristle brush
and just quickly dry that dream coat
into the hair so you get that really
silky finish
so now what we're going to do is we're
going to use the vocal rollers to create
that bombshell look
first of all i spray it with the cool
favorite hairspray this is one of my
go-to hairsprays
a little bit goes a long way so just
spritz the mid-lengths and ends now when
you're putting your velcro rollers in
you just want to take enough hair that
will fit
around the roller so you don't want to
take too much hair because it won't fit
into the roller
grab the ends and make sure they go in
nice and smooth and tucked and then
you're just going to literally
roll that all the way down and now i'm
just going to continue all the way down
the head of hair at the side
and put them in the back as well okay so
now all the rollers are in
what we're going to do is you can have a
go off put some lipstick on get your
face ready
um i recommend that you leave them in
for at least 15 minutes to get some
bounce the longer you leave them in the
better
if you do have time i always like to hit
it with a hair dryer with some heat so
you can just literally warm it up so the
hair can start to set
okay guys so this is the most important
part once all
of the rollers are out we are going to
use our colorado favorite hairspray this
is going to give us a great amount of
control
i'm going to first of all spray that
onto the brush so i'm not going to spray
it directly to the hair
and then i'm going to add this magic
cocktail which is the colorwell extra
shine spray
over the top of my hairspray this is
going to give us a combination of hold
and control
but also a great amount of shine so when
we brush out the curls it has a nice
amount of control
but also like i said a great shine and
we're literally just going to take it
from the front and we're just going to
brush everything back
so at this point what you want to do is
just keep brushing the hair out until
you get the kind of vibe you like
to finish off with i like to go back in
with the extra shine spray
i'm just a real big fan of this because
it gives the hair such a nice shine
it makes the hair look really chic and
then there you have it
hollywood glam bombshell hair and a few
simple steps
making sure you use your velcro rollers
for ease
um try it guys let me know how you get
on
okay guys so i wanted to show you some
of my top favorite products that i can't
leave home without
first up we have the color well extra
shine spray this stuff
really for me is a lifesaver i love
shiny glossy hair i think i've become
well known for it now
spraying this on hair when it's wet when
it's dry before i'm going to use a heat
tool
whatever i can i will use it to
transform the texture and give it an
amazing shine
next up we have one of my favorites
i'm slightly biased this is my new money
hair mask
this stuff for me um is all about
expensive
looking luxury hair it instantly absorbs
into the hair so there's no waiting
around
it's a deep conditioning mask which
hydrates the hair strengthens it and
over a period of time is
proven to show a dramatic difference in
the hair
one of my other favorites is the leandro
limited hair straightener
this bad boy for me is great because we
have the temperature control system
so if the hair is finer i'll turn it
down it has color treated i'll turn it
down
but if the hair's thick and coarse then
i'll make sure i turn it up
and for me it's great because the heat
is always there it's a great performance
straightening iron
and for being essential one of my other
favorites is the leandro limited bristle
brush
this for me is an essential for everyone
because
if i want to brush out waves this gives
me a great control if i want to snatch
the hair up into a high ponytail the
bristles get right through
the hair and if i want to go through
sleek glass-like hair
i get a great amount of control and
shine so for me a good bristle brush
is an essential part of any styling last
but not least
you might not be able to see these
because they're clear but that's the
idea
these are the blanks hair elastics now
what's great about these
is yes they're clear but also you can't
snap them it doesn't matter how much
strength you put in there look
using all my muscle there's nothing
worse than you're getting the perfect
ponytail
and then the elastic snap in so these
have never let me down